so men and women are not the same in
case you haven't noticed
you know we're quite different
physically men have far more upper body
strength
uh women don't you stand naked in front
of a mirror with your girlfriend
and you will notice vast differences
between the build of men and women
so those are just the physical
differences but the thing that i find
interesting
since i've been doing this is i see a
lot of
guys that are mostly plugged in they're
blue pilled
and a lot of women that like to you know
come into this space and be like hey
what's going on over there what's that
guy rich talking about let me check it
out and it's not showing who's he
talking to and what's that all going on
let me click on this video and see
what's going on
and then they go on creepy right so
they like to take something that works
for guys like
we'll tell guys spin plates right if if
if marriage is your goal because this is
what a lot of guys ask me you know
what's the best way to find a good um
you know woman for livestock
date date around date around
non-monogamously
with a bunch of women and find out what
crap looks like and what
great looks like so at least if you're
gonna invest in
mother stock for children you at least
make an educated guess
so yeah you're gonna have to dig through
a lot of a little bit of dirt sometimes
a lot of dirt before you're gonna find
anything that might resemble
gold the same isn't true for women
you know they can't be promiscuous with
impunity
right there's there's big differences
and i'm going to go through all these
right now so
let's go through the evolve firmware uh
as we dive into this so let's talk about
jealousy first men and women get jealous
for completely different reasons and if
you want to know what i'm talking about
uh you can just expand the description
because that's where i always put my
talking po
points the points for each show you get
the idea
so men and women get jealous for
completely different reasons i know i've
probably covered this before but
there's a lot of new eyeballs that come
into this stuff and it's worth rehashing
again
but women get jealous
because they're afraid to lose
provisioning resources
and attention they're not so interested
if we're being honest
in where he's parking his penis okay
do they care yeah of course would they
rather have exclusive exclusive access
to it yes
that's what they want you know they want
it all but at the end of the day
throughout history and as a function of
evolution and i'm gonna
i'm gonna put a lot of emphasis on this
for a reason guys
don't just sit around watching
you know what's new and cool out there
in the mano swamp and think that you're
going to get the best information
there's a lot of young guys out there
you know that have come into the space
and you'll see them pop out
entertainment videos with some
information infused into it
i'll be honest man if i want to ask
somebody
an opinion on something i lean towards
somebody that's been through
parts of life that i haven't seen yet
right
or at least have been to you know
through the parts of life that i've also
seen
not somebody younger than me but there's
a lot of this
i don't know i just want to call it red
pill masturbation because that's really
what it is a lot of guys just you know
running just to get attention and
they're looking for money and that's a
wrong way to go about it man
so some of the information out there
ain't the greatest but i always like to
come back to evo psych
one of the best books i think all of you
guys should honestly read and i always
have this pinned in the top comment of
all my videos
um it's called the evolution of desire
and the author's name is david buss i
believe
and um it's exactly as the title states
you're going to get what you expect out
of that book it's going to go through
how
human beings have evolved to where they
are today over millions of years
and how we survived how we got to the
point that we are today
okay because a lot of people forget
we've been on this planet for millions
of years
you know as uh upright primates that
have eventually
evolved into sapiens which is what we
are today
so you have to look at human past and in
the past women
did not get jealous if you went and had
sex with the neighbor in the other tent
what they were concerned about is am i
going to have provisioning
safety protection from this guy is he
going to feed us in the village
you know are our children that we've
made going to be taken care of
that's what they were concerned with
that's it men get jealous for different
reasons though
men as a function of evolution
especially in the last 10
000 years i think this is highly
emphasized because
you know you start introducing things
like religion marriage
um you know the way that culture just
exploded
and especially you know with
transportation we've seen a lot of
cross-pollinations you know between
different parts of the world
you know you go back ten thousand years
ago it wasn't easy to travel i mean
i can hop on a flight when we're not in
quarantine and i can be over in europe
in
eight hours right you get the point
though
but men get jealous because they don't
have
assurance of paternity okay
they want to know that the baby in her
belly that comes out of her
is his he doesn't want to be taking care
of some other dude's kid
so that's why they're concerned with
what she's doing
with her lady parts simple as that
she talks to another guy a guy hits on
her you know a pickup artist you know
approaches her
uh dude at work asks her out for a
coffee you don't really care as a guy
i mean it's not a big freaking deal if
she's hot she's gonna get hit on i mean
if you've got an attractive girlfriend
she's gonna get hit on it's just a fact
of life
right guys don't typically get jealous
over stuff like that what they're
concerned about is if he's
you know if she's going to pound town
with a convict
in his matrimonial bed and his under
five-year-old children
in the room at the same time that's what
he's concerned about
he wants to make sure that the kids are
his
right women have a hundred percent
assurance of paternity because they
carry the child they birth it they know
it's theirs there's no question in their
mind men however
have questions so men and women get
jealous for completely different reasons
again
men get jealous because of paternity
because there's confusion infanticide is
another problem
in primates it's actually quite popular
and if you don't know what
uh infanticide is it's basically where
the dominant alpha male that uh enters
that tribe
basically kills off the offspring of the
past dominant alpha male because they
don't want those
uh children getting in the way of his
legacy they also take up resources
and the other thing it does is it pushes
the
mama primates and estrus right so
they're so they're ready to get pregnant
again
anyway let's move on to the next one you
get the point men and women get jealous
for totally different reasons
people tell men do what's right
but they'll tell women do what's right
for you okay
and you know this is true this is
absolutely 100
true you've heard this play out time and
time again
you know you see the girls in a
conversation they're like you just do
what's right for you girl you go girl
you know you go and do that thing right
they'll always tell guys do what's right
just do what's right there's no for you
at the end of it
right big big difference pay attention
to that men and women cheat
okay we got that one women athletes oh
this is another good one that i saw pop
up
a few times too this is a good one
female athletes i think i think the
example that they used was women's
basketball
association what is their nba national
basketball i don't know i don't watch
sports
i can't sit around and watch other guys
chase excellence it's just not me
anyway she was complaining that female
basketball players
get paid a heck of a lot less than male
basketball players in the nba
all right see
these these narratives that you hear are
seeking
equality of outcome in all cases and
there's certain scenarios where
performance has to play a role
right and if you've got an elite top
shelf male
basketball player uh that brings in
i don't know ten tens of millions
hundreds
hundreds of millions of eyeballs per
show that sponsors can put their stuff
in front of
they can sponsor you know their jersey
the uh
the athlete will you know speak to the
validity of the
sponsorship and the the greatness of the
sportswear or whatever the hell it is
that he's promoting nowadays it seems to
be all liquor brands right
but you get the idea right women
athletes just don't bring the same
same number of eyeballs to the sport as
male athletes do
it's it's just a fact of life so how can
you pay
women the exact same as you'd pay
that male athlete it just doesn't work
that way
right and you have to understand that
these these differences exist the
problem is is that when
you know you have these plugged in white
knight beta males or these
women that are pushing the agenda of
equality in all areas and egalitarianism
and blah blah blah
let's make everybody the same and men
and women are exactly the same
if men can do it a woman can do it well
men can't have babies you don't see me
crying about that i know that for a fact
right anyway so you so we talked about
the points
in uh sports uh let's talk about the
uh promiscuity issue because that's uh
because that's another one
let me just grab these supers to make
sure i don't let these things fall
behind
mexican mexican iron man mexican iron
man did you drive an r8
recently moved my business purpose and
life f
r comma f oh camifornia i guess he means
california
to south carolina already spinning two
plates during 32 having a great year in
business and paying less taxes to guys
in stream i'm 51 and everything rich
teaches works
thanks rich you're welcome and guys if
you want the playbook
boom it's right there get it off amazon
kindle
print and i did the audible narration
myself
that's where you'll get the deep dive
into all the useful information but you
better be ready to do the work you
better be ready to show up and do the
damn work because some of you guys
are just not ready for that maybe you're
not ready for the truth too
let's go back to promiscuity all right
women today actually believe that they
can be promiscuous with impunity now
part of that is because we've got
hormonal birth control which we didn't
have for millions of years it's only
what was the 60s or so the late 60s
early 70s that that was
available to the masses i know i know
the masses had
like most western countries had
available acts like easy access to birth
control by the late 70s
okay so that comes around and then women
can just have sex with whoever they want
and not get pregnant it's you know
there's 99 percent
um you know success rate with most
contraceptives whether it's hormonal
birth control pills
iuds i mean they got to take the pills
obviously iuds
condoms blah blah blah you get it but
now women can all of a sudden be
promiscuous with impunity or they or so
they think
but there's a big difference they can do
whatever they want okay the masses can
do whatever they want
they want to have you know a hundred
thousand notch counts
doesn't matter doesn't matter to me i
could care less but here's where it does
matter
when guys go around looking for wife
stock because they want to have kids
and they're dating and they see that
there's a bunch of women that they're
talking to
that are for the most part have been
complete and total garden tools
they've been very liberal with their
time and who they spend time with
it's just fact life that's just the way
that it is today but the problem is is
that the data reveals
that women that have had more partners
are incredibly bad for long-term
marriages uh they have a difficult time
for forming a healthy pear bond
to the children's father to the man
and because they've moved around so much
hopping off
you know one eggplant to the other
um it's it's very easy for them to move
on
it's just a fact of life and believe it
or not the numbers get bad after
three partners it's not like it's like
you know it's got to be 30 or 300
but after three partners i mean i think
the data stopped getting collected after
about 11 partners 10 or 11 partners
but after that point the uh chances of
divorce go up dramatically
huge one or two i think it's about 30
percent
once you get past three it just it just
reaches you know the pinnacle mark so
you know i always tell guys look if you
know
one of the things that you got to look
at if you're vetting for wife stock
is what's her notch count look like
because i'm assuming you want to raise
children under the same household not
have to deal with divorce
not have her go crazy or at least low
lower
the chances of her going crazy plus it
brings a bunch of other problems too
right um you know women that have had a
ton of partners are
more often than not single moms they've
uh they've got multiple children
sometimes from different fathers
they've had abortions i'm not just
saying one you know something is
multiple
um there's just a number of of problems
that pop up and
those things don't pop up with men you
know men can't have abortions
you know men can't actually form a
healthy pair bond to a woman
it doesn't matter if his notch count is
10 or
30 or 50 it doesn't really matter
there's there's no consequences to men
being promiscuous and then you know you
always get the argument
like you're telling guys to run around
and do whatever they want that's going
to just ruin all women
women have already ruined themselves you
know society is at the point it's at
it's well past a tipping point okay
women have already chosen this past
long before i ever uploaded my first
video in 2014. okay this has been going
on for decades
before i showed up before i even started
writing the first word in my book
this has been going on for a long time
so this is not
my fault this is not the fault of any of
the men that i collaborate with
this is society you can thank toxic
feminism for that one
all right men and women are the same
no they're not there's big differences
and there's consequences to choices
choices have consequences
right ladies if you're young and you're
watching the show
think about that because smart guys
that pay attention will not or are very
unlikely to wife
up a promiscuous woman if they got their
head screwed on right if they don't hey
i don't care
you know you're plugged into lies that's
your choice
men are the disposable sex while women
are the protected sex
nothing new there right men have always
been disposable
you know warring tribes conflict the
winners
take all the men that are a fighting age
adult males teenage men even teenage
boys you know tweens
they take them all and either enslave
them or try to
incorporate them into their military and
if neither one of those worked out
third option was kill them well women
were preserved
why child bearing okay men have always
been disposable while women have always
been protected
men and women are not the same they're
handled differently and that's okay
just get your head wrapped around it so
you don't get surprised by any
crazy stuff later on in life
uh women can put off having babies for a
career
the way men can that's a big lie isn't
it
they can't well they can try you know
what one of my favorite radio ads is
right now and i don't know who the
marketer is that did this but it's
brilliant
it's it's on the radio and it's like hey
hey girls you know hey ladies you've
been putting off having babies for a
while
and you know you got your degree you got
your uh
career you got promoted you're the
partner at the law firm
sign up now for ivf for only ten
thousand dollars we'll get you knocked
up
no problem at all they include certain
number of treatments there's some
disclaimers
and then somewhere you know about three
quarters away through the ad there's a
little baby like laughing like
like that like you're getting taken for
10 grand lady because you could have
done this before
and had a healthy baby you know the
chances of of of
uh complex pregnancies go up
dramatically
after about the age of 25 to 30.
um you know women will start looking at
these numbers the ones that are aware
anyway
we'll start looking at the numbers and
they'll start to realize you know the
chances of
um you know bearing a child that has
developmental issues on the spectrum is
going to require special needs goes up
i think it's a percent or two every year
after the age of 30.
so you know these 41 year old these 42
year old women that are going out and
getting ivf hey
i know it works i've seen i've seen
babies come out of that
but uh you know men can men can
go and chase excellence all their lives
and have children at 42.
healthy children in fact no problem at
all they can do it at 20 they can do it
at 42.
heck i talked to a guy last week that
was 55
when he had uh twins no ivf needed he
just
wifed up a woman that was 20 years
younger than him right so
it's just the way that it is i'm not
going to spend any time on the
handling of mothers and fathers and
family long because i've already gone a
little bit longer than i wanted to let
me grab the invite link here and let you
guys start queuing up for questions
so again if you have um you got a
question
on tonight's topic awesome something you
want to
ask me about because you think you have
a better solution of the problem
join me live and ask uh
cue a lot of cube because
um just copy and paste that so i can
spam it
there it is so come in and
try to keep it on topic but um if
there's something that you think you
have a solution to
something that i've talked about and
it's a better solution than what i've
talked about let's hear it
i had a guy that messaged me you know
the other week he's like i want to
debate you
i'm i'm 23 and i'm smart and i want to
all right come on my show before the
train work it's always on monday nights
8 pm eastern standard time
come on the show bring your bring your
questions but do not be a value leech
guys you know what i'm talking about
when i say value leech don't show up and
start crying
not listening and sulking especially if
you got more chins than a chinese phone
book don't pull that [ __ ] on me
honestly there should be like a minimum
requirement before you can
you know watch any of this stuff read a
book on any of this stuff
can you at least do 25 push-ups straight
start there
miranda says richard why not just get
prenups why are you so against marriage
can't you just get a fair prenup there's
all kinds of problems that come with
prenups
which i cover in great detail in my book
on the marriage chapter you should grab
it miranda it will help you as a woman
understand the plight of men but
essentially there's a lot of flaws with
prenups
they can be effective but but as more
time passes and the circumstances change
they're not usually worth the paper
they're written on 10
15 years down the road especially if
there's been
big change in circumstances and who's
working who's staying home
and everything that ties into that and
unfortunately everything in family law
is hostile towards fathers it is not
friendly towards fathers it's friendly
towards mothers
and hostile towards fathers and it also
encourages women to behave very badly
during divorce
those are all facts you want to learn
more about that read the chapter in my
book on that
uh digi nomad you got jacked rich and
kept that flame
love it thanks brother appreciate it
amadeus amadeus
that was a very cool song back when i
was a kid there
is a girl i know has been a cc rider i'm
guessing that's carousel rider and her
20 in her 20s anyways on
on a pill a few abortions now trying to
get pregnant for almost a year without
any luck
uh that's why your past catches up with
you yeah
there are there are consequences to
there are big consequences of choices
some greater than others
you